off the gum rose my name is Fred and
welcome back to some more skate 3 so
today we have a lot of skating with her
Bobby so excited grinding kiddies girl
whoa
why are you running my erotic guy got
you [ __ ] oh hey guy how you doing
step aside I want my bench baby love is
good oh man I shut off garbage I hope
garbage loves made back no has anyone
seen my bucket what you can do that oh
man I got to try that what
whoa hey guys don't mind me I'm just a
meatball what is she doing is she trying
to alpha me oh god what are they doing I
met I said hi I'm inside I'm dead
just kidding I'm a fish haha coming for
you [ __ ] oh fish power baby
hahahahahahaha when Bob sees a chick a
girl he likes
hey what's up girl hey girl what's up do
you want to go out in the day now skate
for you son
take this game for nun me I'm at the
opposite hmm
my toes are jiggly pants don't worry Bob
it's gonna be fine and now that I'm I
trust you adventurer Bob surprise Bob
hey are you not a moment
Wow please take my gas my gift
come back here [ __ ] come on man you
forgot it here take a okay
who needs a skateboard anyone alright
let's try and slam dunk I don't know man
this is never gonna work
come on Wow ya know what son of a [ __ ]
there we go nail n-o-o-o what's done
here
this is scary haha let's talk this car
I got it's too fast it's so fast I can't
hold on I'm scared ha ha ha you funny
man
you're funny oh yeah we should good fun
who likes a good bench no one ha ha ha
ha I'm terrified he's so scared oh what
the [ __ ] is he doing
come on I want to go to Hogwarts god
damnit now we'll never be a prostitute
I mean wizard wizard I love [ __ ]
bench as I said badge yes come back I'm
lonely Bob spitting power of justice
looks so funny
it's like perfect oh my god egg why so
late
Bob is my hero man I prize help you
enjoyed this episode if you did please
leave a like it helps me out a lot and I
really appreciate it
so thank you for doing it hit the sky
convert today see you frozen next
episode away if I'm with you I don't
even know what we're gonna do my boy
gonna do it alright that not what you
thought
oh hey guy hiya dine